well we've just been hearing from the
prime minister who's in north wales this
morning visiting a manufacturing site
let's listen in
you are the prime minister of this
country we are in the midst of a cost of
living crisis
surely you have the responsibility to do
something to help people you can't wait
until somebody because cool and you're
completely right
and so i think it's it's crucial to
understand that first of all uh
we realized for a long time that things
were going to be
tough and that's why we put in place a
lot of measures already the money has
started to come through i think it's
very important for people to understand
most people have not yet received the
help that the government has already
allocated so over the course of the next
couple of months you're going to see
about 8 million households get another
326 pounds you're going to see everybody
uh in october uh get help with
the energy support scheme and that was
400 pounds for i just think it's boring
i think people haven't seen the money
come in that and it is coming yeah okay
let me just finish uh another 400 pounds
to help everybody uh plus 150 pounds
help the one in 10 who are disabled they
haven't seen yet that yet it is coming
in but there are two key pinch points
and there are other funds coming in 300
pounds to help pensioners in but are you
going to tell them the choice is to eat
or eat for millions of people the winter
fuel payments so there are two
there are two pinch points ahead
and they are in october and
in
the new year in december january and
uh so i'm describing the cash that's
already coming through and there's
already do you think it's enough
no because what i'm saying saying is
what we're doing in addition uh is
trying to make sure that uh by october
uh by january there is further support
and
what the government will be doing
whoever is the uh the prime minister is
making sure there is extra cash it's too
late to be waiting for them for the new
people because you know you get the two
contenders in a room with you
refereeing so to act now because people
are watching this they want the
conservative government to do something
because the straights are desperate for
people they're very complaining that the
cash is not only coming through now and
has started to come through uh but will
continue
to come through over the weeks and
months ahead but people saying it's all
enough it's not enough and in addition
uh what we are doing is making sure that
we have the
the the fiscal far apart we have the
cash uh to help people more at those two
key points uh in october and in uh in
january so
whoever it is whether it's a man or
woman uh you're going to find that the
uh the new leader the prime minister but
people want something right now
right now yes i know i don't think we've
great respect you've been listening
because uh cash is not only coming in
right now but more is already uh due to
come through what we're talking about is
extra cash uh for october and then
virginia but what you've fundamentally
got to do
is make sure that you do some things to
fix the energy markets and that's what
we were doing yesterday to make sure
what did you get from what what did you
get from that well you have to you have
to wait and see but i'm encouraged by
some of the things that we're seeing
from energy companies about more they
can do to help consumers with uh the
staggering the the payments with making
sure that uh
some of the renewable companies and the
nuclear companies for instance are
making
quite a lot of money uh at the moment
they could do more we think uh to help
their customers the other thing you need
to do is make sure that
we undo the mistakes of the of the past
and have a uh not just go for
hydrocarbons our own hydrocarbons in the
in the north sea and uh again we gave uh
clear clear commitments to those
companies they need to go get on and but
do you really understand how people feel
because people haven't got any money and
then what you also need to do what you
also need to do
is ensure that
you undo the tragic mistakes of the past
and have nuclear capacity and what this
government is doing is now green
lighting nuclear energy when uh for for
the whole of the period of the labor
government not a single nuclear power
plant was a started uh commission so
we are doing stuff in the short term uh
in the medium term and in the long term
and if you ask you know what we're doing
here let me just tell you uh what we've
done thanks to the decisions that this
government took we have a robust
economic uh situation in which actually
we have record virtually record low
unemployment here at uh here at
broughton in uh in north wales you've
got an amazing company employs about
five thousand people do you know they've
come out of this pandemic uh with in a
position no they're gonna be finished in
a position where they are actually able
uh to uh increase their output of wings
by 50 in the next couple of years
i'm going to make the final point which
is going to drive jobs and growth for
the future and that will enable us that
will put us in a strong position and to
continue to do
what we've done
throughout the pandemic and beyond which
is to to
find the cash to help people in the way
that this government has done
we're putting let me repeat we're
putting 37 billion in now that money
will continue to arrive in the course of
the weeks and months ahead there is
going to be there will be more
announcements
in september and those will address the
key pinch points in october and in jack
just one final question in wales you
know the blue wall seats do you think
we've let them down because there hasn't
been much leveling up
on the contrary uh if you look at what's
happened in
uh in wales alone uh it's been uh an era
of fantastic investment in an
infrastructure look at what we're doing
uh in uh with the a55 that we're doing
uh with the north wales railway i've
just
not long ago a place called penn mine
mower uh where we're looking at
improvements to the to the station there
i think there are another 600 uh police
here in wales and there were before i
became uh prime minister uh you're
seeing uh
colossal investments as i say just just
in this factory uh here in broad half of
the uh uh airline passenger wings in the
world are made uh it it's a fantastic
thing i'm glad you said that it's a
fantastic thing your mood is lightning
uh uh here in here you've let wales down
you've done you don't feel that well
down there and what is also happening uh
is that thanks to the support that this
government gave the airline industry uh
during a very difficult time eight
billion pounds we put in then are coming
out of it in a strong position and
this incredible factory uh many of whose
workers uh live in wales
are going to be increasing their output
uh by 50
uh to 2025. that's a that's an amazing
story and it's because of that robust
economic success that we are in a
position
to help people uh as as we've helped
them throughout the pandemic we have the
cash we have the fiscal firepower to do
it
whether you use uh more cash payments
whether you do it through universal uh
credit uh there will be a mixture of
things uh that we will do so people
don't need to worry then we will
continue to do them let me just see
everybody can see
putin's war in ukraine has triggered
global energy spots and nobody is going
to pretend uh that the situation is
anything other than very very tough
but
long
medium-term
we are in a very very strong position
and we will continue to
find more and more renewable energy
we're going to get a 50 gigawatts of
wind by 2030 uh we're already one of the
largest producers of offshore wind in
the world offshore wind is now cheaper
in this country than onshore wind we're
going to be building a nuclear reactor
every year rather than one every uh
every decade we will fix our energy
problems and so i think you know yes of
course people are finding it tough now i
understand that that's why we're helping
them uh with everything that we can do
physically helping them with with the
tax system helping them uh with benefits
helping them with with grants but over
the long term the energy problems of
this country will start to improve
basically uh because
we've taken the long-term decisions that
were necessary and i'm very very proud
of them i'm proud that we've rectified
uh some of the uh mistakes of the
previous uh labour mississippi it was a
bit much hearing from the current labour
leader gordon brown uh saying uh that uh
whatever whatever he said uh the other
you know who who was in power when they
failed to build those nuclear reactors
it was those guys are you going to be uh
answering richie soonac's calls
what he's been texting you trying to get
to get in touch with him i i'm i'm
looking forward to the i think that's
one of those that's one of those
westminster questions uh that doesn't
change the the price of fish there are
plenty of things that do change the
price of fish not the surprise of energy
but that is not one of them and the
price of energy we are going to bring
down by investment in british supply in
renewables in nuclear and all the other
things i'm not going to pretend that
things are easy for people right now you
know your right to push me and because
we're doing everything that we can but
there's more money coming there's more
money coming anyway as a result of the
decisions we've taken there will be
further
help coming
october
and in the new year
i think over the medium term the future
is very bright
thank you nice to see you thank you
thank you
prime minister boris johnson there
speaking uh in north wales let's bring
in our political correspondent mari
aurora who's with me now um mari what
did you make of what the prime minister
had to say some challenging questions
there for him absolutely and i think
he's not going to escape questioning
like that until he leaves on the 5th of
september we know the energy crisis is
looming and worsening the energy price
cap is going to be announced on 26th of
august while he's still in post so i
think he was expecting that and he'll be
expecting more of that kind of grilling
uh in the next few weeks until he does
stand down but what was interesting was
he very much tried to reassure the
public he was talking about how you know
in the medium term and the long term the
future for the uk is bright so he was
trying to say you know all will be well
he talked about how money is coming and
being implemented through uh different
um
initiatives that they've uh brought
through you know paid for by the
windfall tax and things like that in the
coming weeks and he was trying to say
that essentially part of the issue was
some of the money hasn't arrived yet and
therefore people's anxiety rightly so uh
is um higher when that money does start
to come in it may reassure people but
there was also some level of expectation
management also there in terms of the
short-term pain that the uk is likely to
go through he said for instance i'm not
going to pretend that things are going
to be easy they're going to be very very
tough and i think
you know boris johnson there before he
does step down is very aware that
whoever takes over from him as the next
prime minister has got a really tough
job on their hands he talked about how
his uh next his successor the next prime
minister kind of passing almost
responsibility onto them about the two
pinch points as he called it in october
and then also in january and december
and kind of tried to reassure the public
that whoever is the next prime minister
they will focus on those two pinch
points but also to an extent uh pushing
rishi sunak and liz trust to focus on
those pinch points and make sure that
those uh energy price caps when they do
go up they have some level of plan in
place what was also interesting is when
he said we'll have to wait and see about
the outcomes of that meeting yesterday
that really important meeting that sky
news we're covering at 11 downing street
between energy bosses and the current
chancellor nadeem zahawi the current
business secretary quatern
they were discussing how energy
companies could potentially lower prices
for consumers as prices continue to rise
and obviously those massive profits
continue to come in for energy companies
and his response was very much wait and
see about the outcomes of that meeting
so for some people i think that might
not be necessarily good enough i think
they want to know what's happening right
now and obviously we're hearing the same
kind of rhetoric also from both camps in
terms of we're going to wait and see
exactly what kind of help they can
implement when we know exactly the
numbers on the 26th of august he also
admitted that mistakes had been made in
the past he did criticize labor but also
he was potentially looking at other
previous tory governments about energy
policy and a lack of investment in
things like nuclear in things like
renewables and our policy on
hydrocarbons
saying we need to undo the tragic
mistakes of the past so to an extent he
was admitting there that previous
governments have made mistakes about
energy policy and have potentially
contributed to leading us into this
position now where we are so uh you know
in europe but also in the uk so reliant
on global energy markets and not reliant
enough perhaps on our own local energy
and renewable energy that we can make
here in the uk so i would say overall it
was relatively positive he was talking
about how we've got a robust economic
situation low unemployment and things
like that thanks to this government
although with recession potentially
looming
in the winter i don't know how
convincing that necessarily sounds but
in general it was a kind of classic
boris johnson
all will be well type interview but very
much admitting that in the short term
there's going to be some serious pain